[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci beaucoup j'ai l'impression que
cette soirée sur le thème du décalage
oui totalement dédicacé parce que le
décalage les accumule
énormément déjà quand je suis en france
je me sens résolument hongkongaise
alors que quand je suis dans ma ville
natale je suis pleinement française
professionnellement dans un premier
temps j'étais dans la musique
alors que je rêvais juste jouer sur
scène est plus tard devenu humoriste je
voulais à tout prix rechanter à nouveau
et dans ma vie de tous les jours
quand quelqu'un me montre ma carte
d'identité ou ses marques et masculin je
me sens pas vraiment concerné en tant qu
il dit et quand quelqu'un m'appelle
madame je vois pas pourquoi je renierai
le petit garçon qui est en moi voilà ma
vie a toujours été comme ça une sorte de
jeu d'équilibré entre les genres et les
registres sans jamais appartenir à
quelque chose et cette position curieuse
que je vécus dans un premier temps comme
une fatalité
un handicap mais surtout à cause du
rejet de la société est aussi celui des
hommes n'avaient énormément réfléchir
parce que si aujourd'hui à trente à
quarante trois ans
qu'est-ce qu'il est bien conservé je me
dis que c'est que au fond ça m'arrange
bien quand même
ça fait quarante trois ans que je vis en
alternant les casquettes comme ça
peut-être au fond le décalage
il n'y a pas que du mauvais ce n'est pas
si terrible d'être hors norme en jeu
questions pour vous soyez sincère est-ce
que vous vous sentez pleinement à l'aise
avec les normes de la société actuelle
lever la main si vous êtes blanc riche
beau avec des idées de gauche maintenant
une vie de droite est dépourvu de
poignées d'amour
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
personne
non non ne dites pas que vous avez des
ancêtres nés en dehors de la france a
alors là c'est pas plus si vous avez été
au chômage
et vous vous avez des idées
anticapitalistes
nom d'une pipe à 5 euros vous avez une
calvitie la question du décalage nous
concerne tous parce que ces deux règles
qu'on utilise pour le mesurer varie
selon les époques et les cultures
par exemple chez moi à hong kong
il est disgracieux d'être bronzé
du coup chaque année à la rentrée en
france je revois mes collègues
complètement carbonisée avec les ridules
a accentué jeudi à voter au top en
occident et je pense aussi à mes voisins
sud coréen
ils sont forts ils ont inventé une
technique pour agrandir les yeux et
rabaud chez le mâchoire ouais sauf que
en france je n'ai jamais vu une
quelconque fantasmes sexuels vis-à-vis
des lémuriens tous les neuf sont
totalement subjective
alors pourquoi coria près
progressivement je me suis défini mes
propres larmes avec des codes qui me
vont qui me met en valeur à paris
j'adore dire à tout le monde que je suis
avant tout sinon alsacienne
et pas du tout parisienne ceux qui
excusent raymond côté trop aimable
d'ailleurs j'ai déjà penser au titre de
mon prochain spectacle s'intitule
humoriste décalé sauf que en fait c'est
trop tard je vois que tous mes confrères
ont emprunté ce titre spectacle
incassable artiste hors norme
en fait le décalage est déjà devenu à la
mode c'est même une excellente stratégie
de marketing vous voyez dans ma ville
natale
hong kong dont l'ex colonie britannique
quand on est redevenu chinois tout le
monde a eu peur et on a essayé d'avoir
un passeport étranger quand on a
suffisamment d'argent et tout le monde
refuse d'endosser cette identité
hongkongaise qui est tellement
indésirables sauf que j'ai écouté mon
quart et auprès de mon public je la
revendique un bassin les a touchés
comme quoi on fait le décalage permet de
mettre en lumière quelque chose qu'on
oublie évidemment ce n'est pas comme si
j'avais le choix de revendiquer une
identité française sans cesse vous me
rappelez en disant bravo vous maîtrisez
tellement bien notre langue
non pardon vous vous comprenez le monde
maîtrisé
je compris que je ne pourrais jamais
maîtriser la langue de molière comme un
vrai français comme une pure souche
comme on dit alors au fur et à mesure je
vais inventer mon propre accent on croit
parfois que je suis allemande parfois
canadienne parfois québécoise parfois
l'enfant cachet de jane birkin
j'ai inventé
l'accent de l'immigré chic
[Musique]
tout un concept de survie comment ne
m'accorde pas la place au milieu de la
pièce et je trop d'ego pour m'asseoir
sur le côté je me suis créé cette place
à côté de la fenêtre comme ça quand on
signifié qui pourrait se passer autre
chose ailleurs
et cette approche m'a énormément aidé
dans ma recherche d'identité
vous savez quand vous sentez de trop
dans une pièce faire semblant de
regarder le téléphone ne savent pas
grand-chose à 4 ans déjà je jouer à la
poupée
et puis plus tard vers huit neuf ans je
trouvais que j'avais une ressemblance in
nuit avec linda evangelista évidemment
avec le temps les illusions son parti et
je sais que je ressemble plutôt à un ami
cambell jeu je me suis inventé ces
techniques pour me retrouver
sauf que mon adolescence a été tellement
difficile je n'ai jamais réussi à
trouver ma communauté
mon groupe déjà juste une langue
anglaise
donc je ne peux pas partager les valeurs
de la dictature chinoise et plus tard je
croyais avoir trouvé une solution j'ai
entendu vaguement parlé de
l'homosexualité
en fait je suis peut-être juste un jeune
homme homosexuel alors je suis allé voir
mes amis gay sauf que ils m'ont fait
comprendre que j'étais de trop je cite
ce nid
ça nous met énormément de pression de
sortir dans la rue avec toi tu
ressembles à lova moor parfois ok je
reste digne ensuite j'ai entendu le
terme transsexuels transsexuels pas de
bol j'aime seulement ce qui est naturel
je vais mes congés nature et bio
mais pourquoi est ce qu'on cherche à
tout prix à appartenir à une communauté
est ce que c'est parce que je suis la
même couleur de cheveux que vous quand
partageraient forcément les mêmes
valeurs
quand on m'appelle monsieur je
m'accroche viscéralement à mon côté
féminin et quand on m'appelle madame je
vois pas pourquoi j'ignorais le petit
garçon qui est en moi il n'a rien fait
et si mon identité se baser sur le
décalage et si chaque être était
constituée des deux genres finie la
honte pour un homme de verser une larme
et terminer l'embarras pour une femme
d'avant petit duvet le décalage m'a
donné une certaine liberté et une paix
intérieure
au fond on peut être qui on veut il ne
s'agit pas de corée après l'image d'une
femme ou celle d'un homme mais de
trouver le reflet de soi
allard je vous invite tous à vous
débarrasser de cette peur de la
différence au contraire apprivoiser la
cultiver là parce que d'une façon
inattendue
elle pourrait vous rendre sublime
[Applaudissements]